pegi 18
le temps nous est compté
les profits six disques films better
précède le ragnarok
laquerre approche
mon histoire ne peut pas se finir dans
ces bois je devrais partir découvrir qui
je suis qui est l'eau qui je ne te
permettrai pas de public
bien le défi personne
et je veux seulement des réponses et si
ses réponses mène pas une guerre contre
haas car
c'est peut-être ce que mère voulait on
ne sait pas ce que vous voulez ta mère
je connais bien cette sombre expression
odin détient des ressources que nous ne
saurions imaginer et si quelqu'un
pouvait nous aider tu penses à tirs
l'ancien tueur de la guerre de son pays
il est mort
et bien pour un mort odin semble
vraiment désireux de le cacher s'il est
ici nous devons trouver entrée
par les terres de yam spectacle est-il
arrivé
on veut empêcher le ragnarok aider les
gens c'est la seule solution était la
guerre
elle n'est pas la seule solution
arrête de penser comme un père il pense
plutôt comme un cinéma non
tu sembles être une personne calme et
raisonnable
et ugal
déraisonnable
[Musique]
hu
en cas de danger
annick ne sert à rien
contrôler la
[Musique]
et petit luz
on
dire
nous accompagnent tu
[Musique]
tu auras les réponses que tu cherches
dis-moi quelques-unes
la définition